♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" HAPPY
FRIDAY.
AT PRESS CONFERENCE BACK ON
MARCH HE IS VOLUNTARILY WAGE AND
WESTERN EUROPE OUR COUNTRY WILL
SOON FACE FOOD SHORTAGES.
IT'S GONNA BE REAL JOE BIDEN
SAID.
NO REPORTERS DO TO TRANSCRIBE
THE WORDS THAT WROTE THEIR
STORIES BUT YOU MAY HAVE MISSED
IT.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE EVEN HEARD THIS
BECAUSE NOT A LOT OF FOLLOW-UP
PIECES ABOUT THESE MAN-MADE FOOD
SHORTAGES THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
PREDICTING AND THAT IS WEIRD IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT BECAUSE FOOD
SHORTAGES ARE INHERENTLY A BIG
DEAL.
YOU CAN ARGUE THAT THERE EVEN
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN A SLAP
FIGHT BETWEEN CELEBRITIES AT AN
AWARD SHOW.
FOOD SHORTAGES THEY BRING DOWN
EMPIRES AND THEY OFTEN HAVE.
IF YOU HAVE A SHORT FOOD
SHORTAGE OF A POTENTIALLY
DESTABILIZING PROBLEM ON YOUR
HAND.
NOW WE DO HAVE A FOOD SHORTAGE
AND IT'S REAL AS JOE BIDEN
PREDICTED.
THEY RELEASED 26 STATES THAT
HALF OF THE RETAIL STORES ARE
COMPLETELY OUT OF BABY FORMULA.
THAT INCLUDES THE STATES OF
TEXAS, MISSOURI, AND MANY
OTHERS.
THESE ARE MAJOR POPULATION
CENTERS WITHOUT ENOUGH FOOD FOR
NEWBORNS.
IN MEMPHIS AND NASHVILLE, 52% OF
STORES HAVE NO BABY FORMULA.
HOUSTON AT DES MOINES DIMONA
REPORTED SIMILAR SHORTAGES.
IN SAN ANTONIO WITH UNUSUAL HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF SMALL CHILDREN 57%
OF ALL SCORES IN THE CITY HAVE
NO BABY FORMULA.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS,
JOURNALISTS SAW WITH THE REALITY
WAS.
SHE WENT TO A DIFFERENT STORES
IN TEXAS AND NOT A SINGLE ONE OF
THEM HAD ANY WATCH.
>> AYCOCK TALK TO A COUPLE MOMS
OUTSIDE SAID THEY'RE HAVING A
REALLY HARD TIME FINDING FORMULA
AND THIS WHAT WERE SEEING RIGHT
NOW.
THE SECOND TARGET WE WENT
THROUGH AN HOUR IN FRISCO AS YOU
CAN SEE IT'S PRETTY MUCH THE
EXACT SAME THING HERE GROCERY
STORES ARE PRETTY MUCH EMPTY NO
FORMULA TO BE FOUND I'VE TALKED
TO A COUPLE OF MOMS WHO TELL ME
THAT PEOPLE OF SPENT UPWARDS OF
A HUNDRED AND $50 ON FORMULA ON
AMAZON SOME OF THEM CAN EVEN
FIND THE FORMULA THAT THEIR
BABIES NEED.
HER CHILD IS CONSTIPATED AND
MADE A SPECIFIC TYPE OF FORMULA
THEY COULDN'T FIND IT AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Tucker: THAT IS REAL.
SHE IS A VIDEO CAMERA AND SET A
TARGET AND THEY DON'T HAVE BABY
FORMULA.
BABIES NEED TO EAT BUT THEY
CAN'T.
IS THAT A BIG PROBLEM?
WHAT YES IT'S A BIG PROBLEM BUT
HOW BIG?
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS RIGHT
NOW.
BIGGER PROBLEMS IN USING THE
WRONG PRONOUN?
OR TRUMP ODORS PEACEFULLY
TRESPASSING IN A PUBLIC BUILDING
IT SEEMS THAT A PROBLEM THAN
THAT.
SO YOU THINK THAT THE JEWEL BY
DEMONSTRATION WOULD DO SOME GOOD
ABOUT IT AND THEY CERTAINLY
COULD IF THEY WANTED TO THEY CAN
DO ANYTHING, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO CLAIM TO HAVE THE
POWER TO CONTROL GLOBAL WEATHER
SYSTEMS THE POWER TO BEND HUMAN
BIOLOGY TO THEIR WILL SO NOTHING
IS BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THEIR
POWERS.
AND YET AT THIS PARTICULAR CASE
JOE BIDEN IS IN NO HURRY TO FIX
THE PROBLEM IN FACT HE JOKED
ABOUT IT TODAY WATCH.
>> President Biden: IF HE WERE
BETTER MIND READERS IF WE MOVE
AS QUICKLY PROBABLY BECAME
APPARENT TO US.
>> Tucker: IF WE WERE BETTER
MIND READERS GET IT?
IT'S HILARIOUS BECAUSE ACTUALLY
NOBODY CAN READ MINDS.
JOE BIDEN IS BEING SARCASTIC
LIKE A 14-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER LAY
OFF NOT MY FAULT.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT READ MINDS
WITH THE QUESTION IS DOES ANYONE
AND THE WHITE HOUSE READ
NEWSPAPERS?
OR WATCH TELEVISION NEWS?
SUPPLY THE BABY FORMULA WENT
DOWN TO 20% AS FAR AS JANUARY.
THAT WAS NOT HIDDEN KNOWLEDGE IT
WAS PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE.
IT WAS OUT THERE.
IF YOU WERE LOOKING.
HERE'S WHAT REPRESENTATIVE
HEADLINE SAID IN WEST VIRGINIA
BACK IN FEBRUARY, WITH THE BABY
FORMULA SHORTAGE MEANS FOR
PARENTS.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
AMERICANS WERE WORRIED ABOUT NOT
HAVING BABY FORMULA THERE WAS A
SHORTAGE IN FEBRUARY.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE WASN'T
CONCERNED AND THEY KNEW THAT FOR
CERTAIN BECAUSE BRIAN IS THE
DIRECTOR HAS ADMITTED THAT HE
KNEW.
WE WERE AWARE BACK IN FEBRUARY
AND WE'VE HAD A TEAM ON THIS FOR
FOR.
OKAY SO JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN ON
THIS SINCE FEBRUARY.
SO WHY IS THIS STILL A PROBLEM,
WHY IS IT STILL IMPOSSIBLE TO
BUY BABY FORMULA AND STORES IN
SAN ANTONIO TONIGHT?
THEY HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT AND
THE ANSWER IS GREEDY MOTHERS.
THEY ARE THE PROBLEM.
LIKE HIDING GRAIN,
COUNTERREVOLUTIONARY MOMS ARE
UNDERMINING AMERICA'S BABY
FORMULA SUPPLY.
THE ARE QUOTE "HOARDING BABY
FORMULA."
WATCH THEM EXPLAIN.
>> IF YOU ARE IN A PARENT WHO IS
LOOKING FOR FORMULA RIGHT NOW IS
STRUGGLING TO FIND WHAT YOU NEED
EVEN A ROUGH GUESS HOW LONG THE
SHORTAGES ARE NO LAST WHAT
SHOULD PARENTS BE BRACING FOR
HERE?
>> WE'VE ARTIE SEEN AN INCREASE
PAST SEVERAL WEEKS BUT WHAT WERE
SEEING AS AN OMA'S OF HOARDING.
PEOPLE HOARDING BECAUSE THEY'RE
FEARFUL THAT IS ONE ELEMENT OF
IT AND PEOPLE HOARDING BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROFIT OFF OF
FEARFUL NESTS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: NOW WERE DOWN TO
ZIMBABWE IN ECONOMICS.
GREEDY PEOPLE ARE HOARDING IT IT
IS YOUR FAULT AMERICA'S MOMS.
YOU AND YOUR PIGGISH LITTLE
BABIES ALWAYS EATING, EATING,
EATING.
SHOW SOME PATRIOTIC RESTRAINT
AND STOP BUYING SO MUCH FOOD FOR
YOUR KIDS.
YOU GREEDY RECORDS.
THAT'S THE WHITE HOUSE POSITION
ON THE BABY SHORTAGE.
IN FACT AND IT'S POSSIBLE IT
WILL NOT SURPRISE YOU BUT THE
REALITY IS JUST THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD.
AMERICA'S MOMS ARE NOT GETTING
BABY FORMULA BECAUSE THEY'RE
GREEDY OR THE FAT LITTLE BABIES
OR EATING TOO MUCH.
THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
HOARDING BABY FORMULA.
THE MINISTRATIONS PROGRAM
FORMALLY KNOWN AS SPECIAL
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAMS
IS BY FAR THE LARGEST PURCHASER
OF BABY FORMULA IN THE
UNITED STATES, THAT IS TRUE NO
MATTER WHAT THEY'RE TELLING YOU
FROM THE PODIUM AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
STATES AWARD A CONTRACT TO BABY
FORMULA OR MANUFACTURER TO
PROVIDE AUDIT TO WICKED
PARTICIPANTS.
IN THE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
BENEFITS TAKE A VOUCHER TO THE
STORE AND BUY THE BABY FORMULA
FROM THAT MANUFACTURER.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES GET A
KICKBACK FROM THE MANUFACTURER
IN THE FORM OF A REBATE
SOMETIMES AS HIGH AS 85% OF THE
WHOLESALE PRICE.
ANYWAY THE BABY FORMULA MADE
EFFECTIVELY PAYS THE GOVERNMENT
TO MAINTAIN ITS MONOPOLY.
IT'S GOOD BUSINESS FOR EVERYONE
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS THAT
THE ABBOTT NUTRITION COMPANY HAS
MADE A FOAMY STOMACH BABY
FORMULA AS ALL OF ITS EGGS
VIRTUALLY IN ABBOTT'S BASKET.
UNFORTUNATELY ABBOTT JUST CLOSED
IN MICHIGAN BECAUSE OF
CONTAMINATION.
THAT MEANS THAT MINDS OF PEOPLE
USED WIC TO BUY ABBOTT PRODUCTS
ARE FORCED TO BUY COMPETING
FORMULAS AND THE DOING IT ALL AT
ONCE.
SO A GOVERNMENT MONOPOLY
OVERSEEN BY JOE BIDEN CAUSED
THIS BABY FORMULA CRISIS.
SO IF THE GOVERNMENT DOING TO
FIX IT?
WE HERE'S WITH HER NOT DOING.
NONE OF POKING THE DEFENSE OF
PRODUCTION ACT TO PRODUCE MORE
BABY FROM THAT OF COURSE THAT'S
FOR UKRAINIANS ONLY, SHUT UP
AMERICAN MOMS.
BUT IN THE OPPOSITE WHICH IS THE
UNIMAGINABLE.
THEY ARE SHIPPING --
WHO DON'T THE RIGHT TO BE HER IN
FIRST PLACE.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE FLORIDA
CONGRESS SAID THIS IN A VIDEO.
>> DISCUSSANT TO BE BY BORDER
PATROL AGENT THIS MORNING AND
SAID THAT THIS IS DISGUSTING YOU
WILL NOT BELIEVE THIS.
THEY ARE RECEIVING PALLETS AND
MORE PALLETS OF BABY FORMULA AT
THE BORDER THIS WAS TAKEN AT
URSULA PROCESSING FACILITY OR
THOUSANDS ARE BEING HOUSED AND
PROCESSED AND THEN RELEASED
SUBSEQUENTLY INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS THIS IS
WHAT AMERICA LAST LOOKS LIKE.
>> Tucker: THAT IS REAL BY THE
WAY.
IT ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT DENY
THIS.
CONGRESSMAN ALSO UPLOADED THE
PICTURES ON TWITTER THE ONE THE
LEFT IS FROM THE URSULA
PROCESSING CENTER AT THE BORDER.
PALLETS PACKED WITH BABY FORMULA
AND THE SECOND IS FROM AN EMPTY
SHELF HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
PRESERVED FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
SO THERE'S NEVER BEEN A CLEARER
STATEMENT OF THE ADMINISTRATION
IT'S VERY HERE AMERICAN MOTHERS
YOUR KIDS ARE TOO EXPENSIVE GO
HAVE AN ABORTION AND GET BACK TO
WORK IN AMAZON WAREHOUSE.
CONGRESSWOMAN OF CALIFORNIA SAY
THAT OUT LOUD THIS WEEK.
YOUR POOR?
HAVE AN ABORTION TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS SAID THE SAME.
TRY BREASTFEEDING.
IT'S FREE AND AVAILABLE ON
DEMAND.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE SINCE SHE HAS
DONE THAT, BUT THAT IS HER
POSITION.
SO HERE YOU HAVE AN ELDERLY OUT
OF TOUCH RICH LIBERAL LADY
LECTURING STRUGGLING AMERICAN
MOMS TO SHUT UP AND SUFFER IN
SILENCE WHICH BY THE WAY IT
MAKES THE BABY SHUT UP TOO.
NOW IF YOU CAN THINK OF A MORE
PERFECT DISTILLATION OF MODERN
POLITICS OF THE LEFT CIRCA 2022
WITHIN THAT PUSHED MARK SET US
AN EMAIL AND LET US KNOW WHAT IT
IS BECAUSE WE'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING THAT PERFECT.
AND HERE'S THE INTERESTING PART.
THAT IS NOT ALL THE MESSAGE OF
THE BETTE MIDLER'S ARE SENDING
TO MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
WERE FLOODING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THE MESSAGE AND WHICH JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
COME, WE WELCOME YOU WE WILL
SUBSIDIZE YOUR CHILDBEARING
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
EVEN IF WE HAVE TO TAKE BABY
FORMULA FROM AMERICAN CITIZENS
WE WILL HELP YOU.
THAT'S LITERALLY WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
AND OTHER POINTS IS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
SO HOW DO YOU GET THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO PAY ATTENTION
TO AMERICAN CITIZENS TO YOU.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE, BET
MIDLER IS MOCKING YOU GO BUT
BREASTFEED IT IS FREE.
HOW DO YOU GET THEM TO AWAKEN TO
THE FACT THAT YOU EXIST?
THAT AMERICAN CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING, WILL TURNS OUT THERE
WAS A WAY TO DO THAT.
THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE LET ME
LOOK US UP LIKE EVERY CRISIS IN
THIS COUNTRY AFFECT YOU, BUT
INCREASE TRANS-PAPAL
DISPROPORTIONALLY BECAUSE
TRANS-PEOPLE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
SUFFER THE MOST.
THAT'S CONGRESSWOMAN CORI BUSH
ONCE TOLD US THAT NOTHING IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN PROTECTING
BIRTHING PEOPLE.
>> I SAID BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A
SINGLE MOM, AS AN EARTH, AND AS
A CONGRESSWOMAN.
I AM COMMITTED TO DOING THE
ABSOLUTE MOST TO PROTECT BLACK
MOTHERS.
TO PROTECT BLACK BABIES, TO
PROTECT BLACK BIRTHING PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: LIST THE LAST LINE
THAT'S IN TO GET JOE BIDEN'S
ATTENTION SO YOUR KIDS DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT, THEY CAN'T
BE BOTHERED TO BE HELPED AT ALL
THEY CAUSE THIS PROBLEM.
BUT ONCE JOE BIDEN FINDS OUT
THAT THE TRANS COMMUNITY IS
SUFFERING ONCE HE SEES THE FACES
OF THAT SUFFERING HE WILL DO ALL
HE CAN TO HELP.
HE WILL A LIFT THOSE PALLETS OF
FORMULA FROM THE BORDER AND
TRIBUTE THEM TO THE TRANS
MOTHERS WHO NEED THEM.
ONCE HE SEES THESE FACES AND
HERE THEY ARE LEADERS IN
CHATMAN.
STRAIGHT FROM YOUR CALVIN KLEIN
AD.